رئيس مجلس الدولة ، المزيد لصغار ومتوسطي أساقفة الجمعية العمومية
سأعرف غدا
[صفق]
الرفيق تشوم الذي يحدد مفهوم السياسة ،
يمكن للحزب والحكومة 2 تولي مشهد ومسؤولية أكبر من أي وقت مضى
قال إنه يجب بذل كل الجهود ، وفي الوضع الحالي ، يجب بذل جهود روحية
5 أصوات للكبار t الدور
تعزيز النضال العنيد لتحقيق الاستقرار وتطبيع الاقتصاد والحياة
قلت أن عليك أن تفعل ذلك
المكتب السياسي يزور الصين خلف اللجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري
اجتماع السلطة
اعتمد ذروة لقبيلة الأقلية في يونيو night sake la
السياسة في سن المدرسة خلال زيارة للصين
فيما يتعلق بالقضايا التي سيتم معاقبة جميع جايز للفتح والأداء في وسط الغرفة
ناقشنا بحثًا متعمقًا ولخصنا الدرجة المفترضة لـ